so as we told you last night and you may
have noticed cnn pulled its top-rated
anchor chris cuomo off the air for the
crime of helping his brother but you
can't just pull someone off tv you have
to let people know ahead of time
otherwise you're going to have about a
dozen people tuning in and wondering
wait where's the steroid guy so over at
cnn the dwarf king dispatched his eunuch
with the news
that chris cuomo was being pulled off
indefinitely suspended what's so
interesting and tells you so very much
about cnn is we learned today that the
eunuch himself would like chris cuomo's
job ooh the betrayal mr barrier
so interesting so it raises the question
what kind of person is
cnn's media critic
we've come across audio
that answers that question
so here is and we're going to use his
name for the first time brian stelter
explaining to a group of people that he
has fired his nanny who of course
remains nameless because she refused to
get the injection listen to this
you know me and my wife both work full
time we both make enough money to have a
nanny during the day
in new york
and uh and our nanny refuses to get
vaccinated and so we are parting ways
with her
and it was very very sad
that we thought we thought after six
months of seeing the vaccines are all
good and everybody's fine that she would
come around
so the headline here is that cnn's media
critic dismissed blithely dismissed his
little non-white servant because she
didn't obey and that is very very sad
well how sad how sad was he exactly
did he pay her health insurance until
she finds a new job what is she doing to
eat and pay her rent now that she's been
dismissed by cnn's very sad media critic
we don't really care what happens to our
servants do we when they disobey so we
asked cnn today of course we've got no
answer at all which is itself an answer
which is we don't know
we don't care
it tells you a lot
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else